All-seeing evil eyes, teddy bears bent on
murder, and of course, the end of the world.
But which billion-dollar movie was the best?
The fourth film in the "Transformers" franchise,
"Age of Extinction" added Hollywood star Mark
Wahlberg, which helped reinvigorate the series.
In the film, a new villain emerges called
Lockdown, a Transformer bounty hunter who
has come to Earth to kill Optimus Prime.
Unfortunately, the film quickly devolves confusing
large-scale battle scenes and a mess of mind-numbing
CGI — which, to be fair, is kind of the
whole "Transformers" style.
Fans burnt out by "Age of Extinction's" excesses
failed to turn up for the sequel, effectively
ending the franchise.
Released in 2011, "Dark of the Moon" is the
final "Transformers" film to feature original
series star Shia LeBeouf.
In the film, it's revealed that the original
Apollo mission to the moon in 1969 was actually
a covert reconnaissance mission that uncovered
a massive Cybertronian starship.
The robot inside ends up betraying the Autobots,
threatening to tip the balance of power in
their cosmic war.
Once again, Michael Bay worked his magic assembling
a surprisingly high caliber supporting cast
of stars, including John Malkovich, and Frances
McDormand.
Heck, there was even an appearance from actual
Apollo 11 astronaut and national hero Buzz Aldrin!
"From a fellow space traveler, it's a true
honor."
"The honor is mine."
But ultimately the film was let down by an
overwrought story and over-the-top spectacle
that bludgeons rather than delights.
Loosely inspired by a mostly unrelated novel
also named "On Stranger Tides," the fourth
"Pirates of the Caribbean" film sees Captain
Jack Sparrow reunite with a former flame who
delivers Sparrow into the clutches of the
dreaded Blackbeard.
The mission: locate the fabled fountain of
youth with a ship full of zombified pirates.
Despite a promising premise, though, the movie
doesn't live up to the chills and thrills
of earlier entries in the series.
It received poor reviews from fans and critics
alike, causing the sequel, "Dead Men Tell
No Tales" to sink on arrival, ending the Jack
Sparrow saga as we know it… despite his
master plan to save it.
"We shall need a crossbow, an hourglass, three
goats, one of us must learn to play the trumpet
whilst the other one goes like this!"
To its credit, "Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom"
attempts to do something different than its
predecessor, "Jurassic World."
After the island goes awry, our heroes gather
the dinosaurs and move them to a new sanctuary
at Lockwood Manor, residence of Jurassic Park's
original secretive co-founder Benjamin Lockwood.
But it turns out that Lockwood's minions have
other, more sinister plans for the dinosaurs.
Disjointed and disappointing, it coasted on
its big, bold action scenes and the love audiences
still had for the "Jurassic Park" franchise.
But critics and audiences alike were unimpressed,
feeling the film lacked the thrills and chills
of the movies that came before it.
Set decades before the original "Star Wars"
trilogy, "Star Wars: Episode I - The Phantom
Menace" follows veteran Jedi Knight Qui-Gon
Jinn and his protégé Obi-Wan Kenobi as they
uncover a conspiracy on the far-off planet
Naboo, which sets in motion a terrible chain
of events that viewers knew would ultimately
lead to the rise of the evil Empire.
"The Phantom Menace" expanded the galaxy with
new additions like Liam Neeson, Ewan McGregor,
and Natalie Portman, and some cool action
scenes.
Unfortunately, that couldn't save the film
from stiff dialogue and backlash on characters
like Jar-Jar Binks.
"Monsters out there, leaking in here, all
sinking and no power?
When are you thinking we're in trouble?!”
The first in a new wave of Disney live action
remakes, the 2010 big budget blockbuster "Alice
in Wonderland" was led by celebrated director
Tim Burton, who assembled a cast of stars
to bring his mad retelling of the classic
children's story to life.
The film wasn't without its critics, who in
particular called out its generic climax.
But with its talented cast, outrageous style,
and eccentric visuals, audiences largely embraced
the film, helping spur Disney to create a
slew of live action remakes in the decade
that followed.
After a divisive fan reaction to the second
of Disney's "Star Wars" sequel trilogy, Rian
Johnson's "The Last Jedi," J.J.
Abrams was rushed back into the director's
chair for "Star Wars: Episode IX - The Rise
of Skywalker."
The result was an ambitious but haphazard
attempt to tire together four decades of continuity
in a way that was satisfying for obsessed
fans.
And some fans were happy to get any answers
to long-standing questions and resolutions
to ongoing character arcs, not to mention
some break-neck action.
Unfortunately, critics were less than enthused,
and largely knocked the film for a messy script,
choppy storytelling, and one too many confusing
plot points.
In "Despicable Me 3," lovable former super-villain
Gru now works as an agent for the Anti-Villain
League, tracking down other baddies and thwarting
their evil schemes.
When a job goes wrong, Gru is fired from the
AVL, even losing his beloved minions in the process.
But just when he's struggling with what to
do next, he comes face to face with his long
lost twin brother Dru, who wants lessons on
how to be a super-villain.
And it doesn't go great.
"I should have stayed in the boat.
My stomach feels all queasy.
I shouldn't have eaten that pot pie!"
Though a massive hit in theaters, "Despicable
Me 3" split audiences and critics, who felt
it was a little too much of the same.
Going into this live-action remake of the
beloved 1994 animated classic "The Lion King,"
many were skeptical that director Jon Favreau
could bring anything new to the table.
But the result was a lush visual feast, with
audiences eating up the awe-inspiring CGI
visuals created using innovative and groundbreaking
new virtual filmmaking techniques.
Critics, however, were dismissive of what
they considered a soulless, lackluster remake
of an indelible original.
Even the return of the legendary James Earl
Jones as King Mufasa wasn't enough to elevate
the final film.
"One day, Simba, the sun will set on my time
here and will rise with you as the new king."
The breakout stars of the "Despicable Me"
franchise, the pint-sized, overall-wearing
yellow beans called Minions got their own
movie in the wake of "Despicable Me 2."
A prequel to the first "Despicable Me," the
"Minions" movie gives audiences the secret
origin of the little pill-shaped people, as
we follow their origins from single-celled
organisms all the way up to them meeting the
super-villain Gru.
Taking the Minions out of "Despicable Me"
and putting them into their own mini-franchise
could have gone terribly wrong, but with a
cast of impeccable voice actors including
Sandra Bullock and John Hamm, it worked surprisingly
well.
After the blockbuster success of other live-action
remakes, Disney looked to their 1992 film
"Aladdin" for their next big hit.
Before the 2019 live action version even arrived,
though, it was mired in controversy over the
way star Will Smith looked when animated as
a CGI-enhanced blue genie.
But once "Aladdin" landed in theaters, audiences
turned out in droves to see the sprawling
fantasy epic.
Fans gave the young cast high marks for infusing
their characters with heart and earnestness,
but critics panned the film, once again questioning
what the point of these live action remakes was.
"Aquaman," released in 2018, and opens with
the origin of DC's famous sea-faring superhero.
The son of a lighthouse captain and a stranded
woman from Atlantis, young Arthur Curry is
left to be raised on land, ultimately wanting
no part of his watery legacy.
But when a villain threatens war with the
surface world, Curry must finally confront
his destiny in order to stop them.
Led by Jason Momoa, Nicole Kidman, and Willem
DaFoe, the all-star cast gave the film major
acting talent to go with a pumped up action
spectacle from director James Wan.
Brains, however, could be safely shut off
for the duration of the run time.
"Pinocchio.
You risked our lives based on something you
read in a children's book?"
"Wait, it's a book?!"
The eighth film in the long-running "Fast
and the Furious" series, "The Fate of the
Furious" reunited stars Vin Diesel and Dwayne
"The Rock" Johnson in a battle with newcomer
Charlize Theron as the villain Cipher.
In this installment of the seemingly never-ending
franchise, Dom Toretto's retirement is upended
when he's blackmailed into working for the
baddies.
The old crew must band together to discover
why Toretto has seemingly turned villain.
With some shocking twists and new revelations,
"Fate of the Furious" continued upping the
ante, with even bigger and bolder action sequences
than ever before.
Based on the original book by J.R.R.
Tolkien, "The Hobbit: An Unexpected Journey"
expands greatly on the story.
We meet a homebody hobbit named Bilbo as he
is recruited by Gandalf on a quest to help
a group of determined dwarves to find a lost
treasure.
Along the way, he picks up a little gold ring
that will one day change the fate of all Middle Earth.
With Peter Jackson back at the helm, "An Unexpected
Journey" is full of delightful adventure.
Overfull, in fact: it's also bloated and indulgent,
leading to a flabby viewing experience that
turned off fans and critics alike.
The 2017 live-action remake of the 1991 adaptation
of the 18th century French fairy tale "Beauty
and the Beast" brought the fantasy, starring
"Harry Potter's" Emma Watson and Luke Evans
of "The Hobbit."
And it tells the same story you go in expecting
to see: Belle's father is taken prisoner by
a beast, she exchanges places with him, and
unexpected love ensues.
Once again, Disney pulled out all the stops,
loading the film up on luscious eye candy
and top-rate cinematography that dazzled moviegoers,
earning it impressive reviews to go with a
wave of comforting nostalgia.
It's not often that a sequel can reach the
height of its predecessor, but "Frozen II"
broke the mold, releasing in 2019 to rave
reviews, and ultimately becoming nearly as
beloved as 2013's original "Frozen."
"Frozen II" is another frosty musical tale
that reveals the secret origin of Elsa's powers,
and the truth behind the death of her parents.
Funny, romantic, bittersweet, the film mixes
every emotion with gorgeous 3D animation,
while somehow telling a more nuanced and complex
drama than the first without feeling weighed
down or over-stuffed with story.
It's a testament to Disney's finest storytellers
that they were able to recapture the magic
of "Frozen."
Robert Downey Jr. returned in 2013's "Iron
Man 3" as Tony Stark, now dealing with the
traumatic after effects of the alien invasion
shown in 2012's "Avengers."
But he also has to deal with a new threat
in the form of a notorious global criminal
kingpin called the Mandarin, who turns out
to not exactly be what he seems.
"Killian."
"He created you?"
"He created me."
"Custom made terror threat?"
"Yes!"
With some of the best "Iron Man" action to
date, the excitement and drama was all there,
with some added heart and depth thanks to
writer/director Shane Black.
Still, the surprising twist regarding the
Mandarin's true nature riled a lot of fans,
leaving many with decidedly mixed feelings.
After the overwhelming success of 2015's "Star
Wars: Episode VII – The Force Awakens,"
Disney turned the keys of the franchise over
to "Looper" director Rian Johnson for the
sequel.
He succeeded in taking the franchise in a
bold new direction with "Star Wars: Episode
VIII - The Last Jedi."
For many viewers, though, it was the wrong
direction, as Rey discovers that the legendary
Luke Skywalker has given up and become a mopey
cynic.
Add in the slowest chase scene in sci-fi history
and a general disregard for everything that
happened in the previous film and you end
up with a movie that was appreciated more
by critics than fans.
2012's "Avengers" was a massive success, so
for the 2015 sequel "Avengers: Age of Ultron,"
Marvel brought back everyone, including director
Joss Whedon.
And then they stuffed it full of even more
characters, introducing the Vision, Quicksilver,
and Scarlet Witch to help battle the new threat
of the murderous robot Ultron.
While some fans praised the action and character
moments in the film, others felt "Age of Ultron"
was a bit bogged down by excessive world-building
at the expense of the story.
The world it built, though, would help take
the MCU to undreamt heights.
Not many franchises make it to seven films,
but the truly amazing thing about "Furious
7" is that it nearly doubled the box office
of "Fast and Furious 6," turning the popular
series into an absolute unit.
In the film, Dom Toretto and his crew are
confronted by Jason Statham's Deckard Shaw,
the vengeance seeking brother of "Fast & Furious
6" villain Owen Shaw.
The movie was also the final entry for series
star Paul Walker, who was tragically killed
in an unrelated car accident while the film
was in production.
Thanks to the cooperation of his family and
a little CGI magic, producers were able to
complete his performance and give the actor
a touching send-off that proved an emotional
moment for fans.
2003's "Pirates of the Caribbean: The Curse
of the Black Pearl" proved audiences would
turn out for a movie based on a Disney theme
park ride - and the 2006 sequel "Dead Man's
Chest" proved audiences couldn't get enough
of Johnny Depp's antics as Captain Jack Sparrow.
In this one, Will is ordered to help find
Jack and in turn the fabled Dead Man's Chest,
at the request of the corrupt Lord Beckett,
all while fighting off the legendary Davy
Jones and his mystical pirate ship the Flying
Dutchman.
So big it couldn't get out of its own way,
"Dead Man's Chest" set the franchise on a
course for the many hits that followed.
In 2016, "Star Wars" went where it had never
gone before, releasing a standalone live-action
theatrical film set outside of the main saga.
"Rogue One: A Star Wars Story" told the story
of how the Rebellion in "A New Hope" got the
Death Star plans to begin with, with recruits
Jyn Erso and Cassian Andor leading a suicide
mission to set the stage for the fall of the
Empire.
A darker, grittier take on the franchise,
"Rogue One" was celebrated for it's gritter
take on the mythos, and has been lauded by
some hardcore fans as the best of the recent
"Star Wars" films.
Released in 2009, the sci-fi adventure "Avatar"
left viewers' jaws on the floor with its immersive
vision of a far-off alien world.
The film is centered on a race of blue-skinned
natives called the Na'vi, as their home is
invaded by greedy corporate mercenaries who
want to steal their resources.
Filmed using a new, groundbreaking 3D technology,
"Avatar" proved a moviegoing experience unlike
any other, driving fans into theaters in numbers
nobody had ever thought possible.
More than a decade later, it's still the top
grossing film of all time.
The third in director Christopher Nolan's
trilogy, "The Dark Knight Rises" finished
off what many consider to be the greatest
comic book movie series ever produced.
Set almost a decade after the previous film,
"Rises" finds Bruce Wayne retired when a new
and more insidious villain called Bane shows
up on the scene.
When Bane's plot to destroy Gotham proves
too much for him, he's forced to sacrifice
everything to save the city.
While for many "The Dark Knight Rises" could
never live up to "The Dark Knight," it still
remained a satisfying and action-packed conclusion
to the three-film saga, neatly tying the whole
story together.
The 2019 sci-fi superhero actioner "Captain
Marvel" was the first MCU film with a woman lead.
The film is set in the 1990s, when a valiant
space ranger crash lands on Earth and discovers
she's actually a human woman named Carol Danvers.
With the help of a younger Nick Fury, Danvers
must recover her lost memories and uncover
the truth behind the conflict between two
warring alien races.
Fans' expectations for the film were so high
that they proved impossible to meet, but "Captain
Marvel" remains a solid entry in the MCU,
and better than it’s often given credit for.
After the original "Jurassic Park" trilogy
petered out in 2001, it would be 14 years
before "Jurassic World" rebooted the franchise.
The 2015 tentpole brought in new stars Chris
Pratt and Bryce Dallas-Howard for a story
about, you guessed it, dinosaurs running rampant
through a tropical island theme park.
Only this time, the park is filled with thousands
of tourists for maximum carnage.
Debuting with good reviews from both critics
and audiences, "Jurassic World" was lauded
for its successful mix of modern thrills and
classic "Jurassic Park" storytelling, ultimately
leading to two sequels of its own.
The first film to ever earn a billion dollars
at the box office, 1997's "Titanic" featured
Leonardo DiCaprio and Kate Winslet as star-crossed
lovers Jack and Rose.
The poor Jack and the rich Rose find true
love just as the doomed ship famously strikes
an iceberg and pulls most of the film's all-star
cast straight to the bottom.
"Jack!
This is where we first met!"
A tale of love, lust, betrayal, and revenge
set against the backdrop of one of history's
greatest ocean disasters, the film has something
for everyone.
It's no wonder it has remained a beloved classic
for a quarter of a century.
Director Todd Phillips turned 2019's "The
Joker" into a gritty and grounded psychological
drama, and an incisive and surprising takedown
of modern life.
Touching on such weighty issues as the mental
health system and wealth inequality, star
Joaquin Phoenix turned the clown-faced super-villain
into a deeply troubled soul who resorts to
violence when society turns its back on him.
The results struck a chord with audiences,
who flocked to see the timely film despite
few action scenes and almost no big special
effects.
Unsurprisingly, a sequel was announced in
2022 and is already in the works.
The 2019 blockbuster "Spider-Man: Far From
Home" didn't just build on the legacy of the
previous six "Spider-Man" films, it also provided
the first follow up to the cataclysmic events
of the MCU-defining "Avengers: Endgame."
The story, about Peter dealing with grief
after the loss of mentor Tony Stark and a
surprising betrayal by new mentor Mysterio,
allowed fans to process their own feelings
of grief over the death of Iron Man.
Mixing coming-of-age teen drama with high
stakes superhero action, "Far From Home" showed
that the MCU was now centered around a new
figure - and Spider-Man was up to the task.
Based on the series of hit young adult fantasy
novels, 2001's "Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone" introduces audiences to a young orphaned
boy sent to attend Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry.
There he meets new friends who help him discover
the truth when a terrible evil begins threatening
him and the school.
"We know about the sorcerer's stone.”
“Oh."
While the film wasn't as refined or slick
as its successors would be, it drew audiences
of all ages with its fantasy thrills, family
friendly adventure, and magical mystery, and
turned unknown child actors Daniel Radcliffe,
Emma Watson and Rupert Grint into international stars.
Another blockbuster from the MCU, 2016's "Captain
America: Civil War" saw the Avengers dealing
with the aftermath of a mission gone wrong.
When Cap's old sidekick Bucky — now the
Winter Soldier — is accused of killing the
Wakandan King, our heroes are forced to choose
just whose side they’re on, Cap's or Iron Man's.
In addition to bringing back old favorites,
the film introduced two big new players for
the first time.
Chadwick Boseman makes his first appearance
as the Black Panther, while Marvel also introduced
Spider-Man into the MCU.
Between the big superhero debuts, the over-the-top
hero-on-hero action, this one was a crowd pleaser.
Based on the novel by author Michael Crichton,
1993's "Jurassic Park" was quickly optioned
for a big budget feature film by none other
than Steven Spielberg.
He ditched the book's hard science in favor
of an awe-inspiring adventure, with groundbreaking
special effects that made dinosaurs more real
than ever before.
"Your scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could, they didn't stop
to think if they should."
When dinosaurs are cloned, hero scientists
Sam Neill, Laura Dern, and Jeff Goldblum have
to stop them from running amok.
One of the most thrilling and unexpected big
screen joyrides in movie history on its release,
audiences and critics were in awe of the movie
billed as "65 million years in the making."
They could do it, and it turned out they should.
In an unparalleled and monumental undertaking,
the fledgling Marvel Studios set out to craft
the first ever true cinematic universe.
After the films "Iron Man," "The Incredible
Hulk," "Captain America" and "Thor" introduced
the individual heroes, 2012's "The Avengers"
brought them all together in a way never seen
in movies before.
The story?
Stop Loki and his alien army from conquering
Earth.
A sharply written, slickly executed action
blockbuster, not a moment is wasted in the
superhero adventure, which thrilled audiences
and set the stage for a decade of box office
dominance by Marvel.
It all came to this: 2021's "Spider-Man: No
Way Home" brought back characters from all
seven previous Sony and Marvel Spider-Man
films, as the Spider-Men of three universes
banded together to try and save the MCU's
Peter Parker from his own mistakes.
Fans thrilled to see Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield stand shoulder to shoulder with Tom
Holland as they fought a menagerie of villains
from all three realities.
With enough Easter eggs and guest stars to
force fans into theaters despite a global
pandemic, "No Way Home" proved one of the
biggest crowd-pleasers Marvel has ever produced.
Loosely inspired by Hans Christian Andersen's
"The Snow Queen," 2013's "Frozen" centers
on Elsa, who fears her own icy supernatural
powers, and has grown estranged from her younger
sister Anna as a result.
But when Elsa unwittingly unleashes her power
and covers the kingdom in an icy winter, Anna
must rekindle their relationship to save everyone.
With memorable musical numbers and a timeless
story of family, "Frozen" became an instant classic.
Crossing age and gender lines, it was beloved
by audiences of all stripes, helping it become
an unexpected billion dollar hit.
2003's "Finding Nemo" was a massive blockbuster
and an instant family classic.
But it would be more than a decade before
Pixar followed up with 2016's "Finding Dory,"
which follows Nemo's forgetful friend Dory
as she sets out to regain her memory and find
her long lost parents.
And along the way, she inevitably meets a
host of new animated undersea buddies.
"Finding Dory" was the rare sequel to be not
only a bigger earner than its predecessor,
but an equally crowd-pleasing film, as fans
and critics alike praised it for its heartwarming story.
2004's "The Incredibles" was one of Pixar's
most beloved films, so it's no surprise that
fans turned out in droves for the 2018 sequel
"The Incredibles 2."
After the fallout from the first film's climactic
battle, the government shuts down their superhero program.
But when a wealthy tycoon offers Mr. Incredible
and Elastigirl the chance to become heroes
again, they jump at the chance, only for Elastigirl
to uncover a sinister plot to end all superheroes for good.
With loads of superhero action, delightful
comedy and classic Pixar heart, "Incredibles
2" was a hit in every sense of the word.
For a full decade, audiences watched Harry
Potter, Hermione Granger, and Ron Weasley
grow up on screen as they fought to stop the
return of the Wizarding World's greatest villain,
Lord Voldemort.
It all culminated in 2011's "Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows, Part 2," as the eighth
and final film in the series saw our heroes
take on Voldemort's army in the Battle of Hogwarts.
"Deathly Hallows, Part II" was not only the
highest grossing film in the franchise, it
also was the most critically acclaimed, earning
three Academy Award nominations and a 96%
on Rotten Tomatoes.
They truly saved the best for last.
After Disney bought the rights to "Star Wars"
in 2012, it was inevitable that new movies
were coming.
The first was 2015's "Star Wars: Episode VII
- The Force Awakens," which brought back original
characters Han, Leia and Luke and paired them
with a new generation of heroes in the form
of Rey, Finn, and Poe.
While it was knocked for being something of
a rehash, fans loved the familiar, and critics
praised the picture for re-energizing the
franchise with a promising new story.
"No!"
Set in a world of anthropomorphic talking
animals, 2016's animated smash "Zootopia"
features Judy Hopps, an upbeat bunny who enlists
in the local police force.
Through a series of mishaps, she winds up
stuck with Nick Wilde, a jaded fox con artist
who wants anything but to be paired with Hopps.
They soon uncover a major conspiracy that
threatens the city, and must work together
to get to the truth.
Mixing elements from the best buddy cop comedies
with the charms of the best animated family
films, "Zootopia" ultimately won the Academy
Award for best animated film.
Combining every major Marvel franchise, with
heroes from "The Avengers," "The Guardians
of the Galaxy," and the recently incorporated
"Spider-Man," 2018's "Avengers: Infinity War"
saw Thanos arrive on Earth to complete his
collection of Infinity Stones, the powerful
ancient relics that will give him the power
to wipe out half of all life in the universe.
An edge-of-your-seat thrill ride from start
to finish, the movie managed to mix dozens
of heroes and villains together in a story
with a vast canvas.
It satisfied fans of every character, and
delivered something bolder and bigger than
anyone imagined, subverting expectations with
a twist ending that left audiences gasping
in disbelief.
"I'm sorry!”
After 50 years and 23 films, 2012's "Skyfall"
marked the first James Bond movie to crack
the billion dollar mark.
In the darkest installment yet, a critical
mission goes wrong and MI6 is compromised.
Daniel Craig's Bond is the only agent left
that can be trusted, and is tasked with tracking
down and stopping a madman named Silva, an
insidious threat from M's past who has come
back for revenge.
Buoyed by newcomers like Ralph Fiennes, the
film was a tight, gripping spy thriller of
the highest caliber, and many fans and critics
still consider it the high point of modern Bond films.
Released in 2019, "Toy Story 4" was an unexpected
sequel, as the beloved franchise was seemingly
over for good.
Luckily, it wasn't.
While on a road trip with their new owner,
Woody is reunited with his old flame Bo Peep,
who tries to get him to run away with her.
Now Woody must decide whether he wants a future
with a child as he has always believed was
intended, or the freedom of a new life as
a rogue toy.
Once again, Pixar knocked it out of the park
with fans and critics alike.
Now the only question is whether there will
ever be a "Toy Story 5."
Combining lush, vibrant, and expressive animation
with a number of iconic new songs and powerful
storytelling, 1994's "The Lion King" was a
worldwide sensation.
In this animated Shakespearean tragedy, young
cub prince Simba runs in fear after his uncle
Scar murders his father, King Mufasa.
But when Simba's childhood friend Nala finds
him, he is urged to return to the pride and
save his former home from the cruelty of his
uncle.
One of the most acclaimed and beloved films
of all time, "The Lion King" has enjoyed multiple
re-releases over the years to help it cross
the billion dollar mark.
Marvel Comics' first Black superhero debuted
in 1966 in the pages of "Fantastic Four,"
but it would take until 2017 for "Black Panther"
to get his own feature film.
Expectations were through the roof, but even
the most fervent fans were blown away by director
Ryan Coogler's vision of afro-futurism.
But it was actor Chadwick Boseman who provided
the heart of this story, which centers around
a challenge to the ideologies of Wakanda by
T'Challa's cousin Killmonger.
Tragically, Boseman passed away in 2020 at
the age of 43, leaving an indelible legacy behind.
"Wakanda forever!"
2008's "The Dark Knight" is one of most critically
acclaimed superhero films of all time.
Heath Ledger stars as the Joker, who sets
out to prove humanity isn't worth saving by
exposing all the hypocrisy, greed, and selfishness
beneath the surface of Gotham City.
Directed by Christopher Nolan and starring
Christian Bale as Batman, "The Dark Knight"
was a tour-de-force.
Tragically, star Heath Ledger died just months
before release, but he'd get the last laugh
on his doubters as his performance earned
him a posthumous Oscar.
36 years after the original "Top Gun" debuted
in theaters, 2022's "Top Gun: Maverick" blew
audience expectations out of the sky with
the return of Tom Cruise's legendary fight
pilot Pete "Maverick" Mitchell.
Called back into service to help train a group
of young recruits for a crucial mission behind
enemy lines, Maverick gets more than he bargained
for when he learns one of the cadets is the
son of his old friend Goose, who died in an
accident for which he has long felt responsible.
"My dad believed in you.
I'm not gonna make the same mistake."
Praised by critics, "Top Gun: Maverick" soared
to become one of the best reviewed films of
the year, and the best of Tom Cruise's long
career.
The culmination of more than a decade of films,
2019's "Avengers: Endgame" might be the most
highly anticipated superhero movie ever, coming
a year after "Infinity War" left fans stunned
by Thanos' victory and the loss of half of
our heroes.
"Avengers: Endgame" sees the surviving heroes
engage in a desperate time heist to try and
alter reality itself.
But Thanos has other plans, only stopped when
Tony Stark sacrifices himself to save the
entire universe from oblivion.
Featuring action on a scale never before imagined,
"Endgame" was the ultimate theater experience
for an entire generation.
Coming out a decade after "Toy Story 2," 2010's
"Toy Story 3" sees the toys from Andy's room
mistakenly donated to a daycare center, where
the plush monstrosity Lots-o'-Huggin Bear
rules with terror.
Woody, Buzz, and the rest must band together
to lead a toy rebellion in order to save themselves
from certain doom.
Receiving universal critical acclaim, "Toy
Story 3" served as a perfect conclusion to
the story of Woody, Buzz, and the gang.
Of course, another sequel eventually followed
and a fifth may be on the way, but "Toy Story
3" still remains the best reviewed film in
the series.
"The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the
King" capped off the epic fantasy film trilogy
from director Peter Jackson in 2003.
The final film in the series sees Sam and
Frodo making their final journey to the steps
of Mount Doom, while Aragorn, Gandalf, and
an army of men confront Sauron's forces in
a final showdown between the forces of good
and evil.
A box office smash, "Return of the King" put
a perfect bow on the "Lord of the Rings" film saga.
Not only is it the highest grossing film in
the series, it also took home the Academy
Award for Best Picture – the only fantasy
film to ever do so.
"You bow to no one."